hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel uh right now it is just starting
to get cold over here in Chicago and as
a result the down Badness is hitting me
like a truck uh but anyways I'm gonna
persevere through it and talk about some
graph databases so let's get into things
alrighty so today's video is all about
graph databases which as you may have
guessed are specifically useful for
holding storing and reading and writing
quickly graph data so graph data is
anything that is best represented by a
bunch of nodes and vertices or edges
whatever you want to call them and as
you can see I have presented one here
below where even things like the edges
themselves can have values the nodes
themselves can have keys and or values
and in particular this graph is going to
represent who is trying to flirt with
who as you can see it's a direct graph
so you've got Megan Fox and Kate Upton
over here trying to flirt with Jordan
unsurprising and then you've got a few
uh Bozo celebrities trying to flirt with
them but uh you know they're not really
reciprocating that so you've got Shia
LaBeouf Machine Gun Kelly of course
going to shoot his shot with both and
then Justin Verlander who to my
disappointment is actually now married
to Kate Upton so the graph database
video itself is mostly inspired by neo4j
which we'll talk talk about towards the
end of this one but for now let's think
about this a little bit more abstractly
so I'm going to start the video Itself
by basically covering the concept of
native versus non-native graph databases
now the meaning of that effectively is
that a non-native graph database is one
that takes a typical existing database
and basically writes a query language on
top of it such that you can perform
graph traversals relatively easily so
let's see how we would actually perform
something like a graph traversal using a
relational database so keep in mind with
a relational database whenever we have
many to many relationships like we
require in a graph we would typically
use a table that basically just has the
primary keys of the nodes that you're
joining and that would indicate an edge
so again here's our people table over
here on the left we've got all of our
lovely characters and then of course
we've got our flirting table with a from
and a two column now keep in mind to
keep this thing as fast as possible we
probably want to put an index on the
from column and then we also want to put
an index on our ID column so we can find
people as quickly as possible
so why is it that this implementation of
a graph is a little bit less than ideal
well let's try and demonstrate that by
answering the question who has Machine
Gun Kelly hit on so first by doing this
we would start by finding Machine Gun
Kelly so that is going to be node with
ID number five and then we would check
out our flirting table so the first
thing we would have to do is because
this is an index we have to binary
search it so we binary search it and we
end up seeing that he's flirted with
people too and person three and
basically from there now we have to go
back to our people table and binary
search that and we can see that
eventually he's flirted with Megan Fox
and Kate Upton as was the case in our
original graph that's basically what
we're going to be relying on for the
rest of this video there are a couple of
problems with that though it takes a lot
of time to actually find that result for
starters in order to find you know the
primary keys of who we flirted with that
is a logarithmic operation relative to
the number of edges in our graph and to
actually go ahead and then take those
kind of primary key ease and get the
people from them that is a logarithmic
operation
relative to the number of people or
nodes in our graph and so as a result of
that that is going to be pretty slow
when we think of a graph typically when
we have an edge we can just jump to the
other node right we can do it in uh
basically constant time complexity and
so using a relational database to build
a graph probably isn't your best idea
it shouldn't be the case that as we add
more nodes to the graph it literally
gets slower to Traverse that shouldn't
really matter at all
okay so let's think about a
non-relational implementation of a graph
this could be a little bit better so as
you can see since we have more data
locality since we don't have a set of a
structure we can actually just have a
field that's a list and it stores the
IDS of the people that we've hit on so
again let's use Machine Gun Kelly as our
example so we can see pretty easily
right off the bat due to our great data
locality that he's hit on people two and
three so we don't have to go to another
table and do a binary search so we got
rid of you know scaling our complexity
due to the number of edges however in
this case we still do have to take two
and take three and do a binary search
over here in order to find them and so
it's still becoming more and more
expensive to Traverse our graph
as the number of nodes in our graph
increases like I mentioned this is the
size of the nodes and so as a result of
that again just not an ideal
implementation now you may say to
yourself well oh you know like couldn't
we just go right back to Megan Fox over
here couldn't we go right back to Kate
Upton over here
yeah we could but keep in mind that they
also have edges and as a result if we
wanted to store the actual full node and
do traversals we would potentially be
just duplicating our graph n times over
it could be very very bad storage wise
so
let's now talk about the last piece of
this video the last piece of our puzzle
which is going to be the native
implementation or basically what neo4j
does which is why it is so popular as a
graph database so as you can see right
here we've got a couple of unique Fields
we've got an address field which is
representing basically the address of
this thing on disk or memory whichever
you want to use and then additionally
we've also got a nodes and an edges
table so the edges themselves are
effectively objects in our database so
as you can see for every single person
we've got a pointer in the database to
an edge address and what that's going to
do is then actually point us right over
here to our edges table where it's
corresponding and then our Edge in turn
is going to point right back to the
original node and what that does is
instead of having to actually just
binary search our index over and over
and over again we can just jump to the
proper place on disk now do keep in mind
that disks generally speaking are meant
for sequential access they're not really
meant for random accesses however if you
can save this much time complexity it's
still going to make a super significant
difference so another thing you may note
that's actually kind of interesting is
for MGK for example recall that he's got
multiple edges and meanwhile there's
only one address for him the reason for
that being that that's what this next
address field is doing over here so if
we go to the edge that is at the address
10 we can see that it's pointing to node
two so that's pointing back to Megan Fox
however at the same time it also points
to the next Edge right here so that if
we're trying to Traverse all of Machine
Gun Kelly's nodes or the ones that it
points to we can go quickly from this
Edge to this Edge over here see that
it's pointing to the thing in address
three and then jump right back to see
that Machine Gun Kelly is also hitting
on Kate Upton
now the really nice thing about this
like I mentioned is it is constant time
complexity we're just jumping around we
don't have to Loop through the number of
nodes every single time the amount of
computation that we have to do does not
scale relative to the number of nodes or
edges in our graph and so as a result
this thing is a lot more efficient the
term that neo4j officially uses for it
is called index free adjacency because
we don't have to use an index it speeds
things up pretty considerably
okay so the last kind of point to make
over here is that in neo4j in particular
we have a lot of acid transactions that
we need to make the reason being that a
lot of times there are operations that
we may want to basically perform them on
multiple nodes that are connected to one
another for example let's say we said
take this node here and every single
node that's connected to it add three so
that would look like this right here and
it's important that all these operations
go through or they all fail or just in
general we want them to be Atomic so of
course for doing something like this it
would be the same as our other asset
transactions in normal databases we need
to write ahead log we need to put locks
on all of those nodes so we don't incur
any race conditions and as a result of
course that can slow things down and
even more problematic scenario is going
to be when these things are distributed
across different partitions of the graph
so as you can see if I want to add 3 to
all of these nodes over here here and
here they're physically on different
computers and unfortunately what that
does mean is that we're going to have to
run a two-phase commit the nice thing
that neo4j does do for us is it'll
basically say okay well it's only these
three nodes involved in the two-phase
commit so let's make this guy the
coordinator
and these two are listening basically to
the two-phase commit
and then this fourth node over here we
don't really have to worry about that it
can proceed as normal
proceed as normal
and that is obviously going to be super
useful because if every single node was
involved in the two phase commit then
our entire system would basically have
to wait while that right went through so
in conclusion graph to databases are
probably not going to come up too much
in your system design interviews and
frankly probably not even that much in
your career either but not only is it an
interesting topic but if they do ever
come up you're going to want to know why
native graph databases are a lot quicker
and a lot better and of course why that
is anyways guys hope this video was
useful and I will see you in the next
one